neuf hommes de 25 à 35 ans à la barre du
tribunal correctionnel pour ce premier
volet de cette vaste affaire de
violences à caractère raciste
l'audience du jour était consacré à ce
que l'on appelle une ratonnade une
agression gratuite et ultra violente à
l'encontre de deux jeunes auxerrois
d'origine maghrébine attaqué à coups de
pied coups de couteau barres de fer et
poings américains
l'une des victimes gardent d'importantes
séquelles six ans après beaucoup de
blessures manière physique parce que
j'ai encore des marques qui resteront à
vie malheureusement également une
dermatose au niveau du crâne un niveau
psychologique donc c'est vrai que ça m'a
fortement touchée surtout comment en
première année de fac également au
niveau familial quand même parce que mes
parents étaient très choqués ce qui nous
a poussés aussi à déménager
l'association sos racisme est également
partie civile dans ce dossier
il est évident que la seule motivation
commune à tous et ces jeunes gens à
l'époque et aujourd'hui adultes étaient
uniquement leur racisme l'antisémitisme
il était tout à fait évident que ce
geste racisme se devait d'être aux côtés
des victimes physiques aujourd'hui
puisque est un jeune homme qui s'est
fait agresser uniquement parce qu'il a
une tête d'arabe
la plupart des prévenus appartenait à
l'époque des faits un groupuscule
d'extrême droite
il plaide l'erreur de jeunesse il y
avait un mot pour résumer ses erreurs de
jugement d'adolescence fautes de
jeunesse
avec des dérapages avec ce qu'il a
expliqué il avait été lui-même agressé
temps jeunes par des maghrébins dans son
lycée ce qui lui a donné ensuite une
sorte de haine viscérale à l'époque
cristallisé par l'effet de groupe
le procureur de la république a requis
cet après midi entre six mois avec
sursis et 4 on ferme à l'encontre des
sept agresseurs la décision devrait
intervenir dans la soirée sur